-Yesterday, Eminem released
a freestyle rap video.
Did anybody see that?
Did anybody see --
[ Audience cheers ]
In which he took on a number of
political and social issues
and ended the video
by calling on any of his fans
who still support Donald Trump
to decide
between Trump and himself.
Take a look.
-[ Rapping ] ♪ And any fan of
mine who's a supporter of his ♪
♪ I'm drawing in the sand
a line ♪
♪ You're either for or against ♪
♪ And if you can't decide
who you like more ♪
♪ And you're split
on who you should stand beside ♪
♪ I'll do it for you with this ♪
♪ ...you ♪
-Powerful stuff.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Powerful stuff.
And I was inspired by that,
so tonight, I say
to any fans of this show
who are also big fans
of Donald Trump,
it's time to make a decision,
guys.
Get off the fence.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Do you support him,
or do you support this show
that constantly mocks
and denigrates
everything about him?
I know it's a tough call,
but the time has come
to make a decision.
Now, I'm not much of a rapper...
[ Laughter ]
...but here it goes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Rapping ] ♪ My name is Seth,
and I'm here to say ♪
♪ If you like Trump,
then go away ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]